hey what's up guys how you guys doing
it's good to be here my name is hans uh
i'm asian
i love being asian it's [ __ ] awesome
my cock's just the right size
it's [ __ ] awesome dude i can go
around wearing tight pants i don't look
ridiculous with a giant bulge
you guys look stupid with your big [ __ ]
over there
chinese
i'm from a province in china called
south korea
it's right next to japan province
a lot of people like uh yeah you know
the whole small
[ __ ] thing it's like even if that was
true and it's not
mine's pretty big but even if it was
it's not like we'd hear that and be like
oh we got small dicks
okay we'll go find a new hobby sorry to
bother you ladies
we wouldn't just give up okay we would
start studying because that's what we do
man we learned how to use it like a
sewing machine
martial arts
hitachi
so yeah i mean i'm single uh have yet to
uh
sexual intercourse during the pandemic
i uh i have yet to meet my soul mate i'm
beginning to think
maybe it's her fault she needs to get
out more
she seems like a loser i think i could
do better
nerd i was
on a date with this beautiful lady and
she was like you men think you're so
cool but
actually women are better because we all
have 3d printers in her vaginas
because we can make a baby
really pretty you can make a baby and i
was like
actually your womb is the 3d printer
because that's what makes a baby you
know
your vagina's the tray
it only prints one thing with lots of
errors
[Applause]
it takes nine months to print
and the whole time it's printing it's
complaining
[Music]
needless to say i did not see any trays
that night
ladies am i right crazy
uh my friends are like dude you need to
learn how to talk to women
i'm like yeah or maybe women should
learn how to listen to hans
why don't you want to hear about the
federal reserve
it's so complicated it's very cool um
i don't think i can ever have sex with
dudes i'm glad women
still do that now uh
heroic ladies thank you uh i've never
looked at a beautiful woman i've been
like wow she's gorgeous but
is there a version of her that's bigger
and hairier and has less kindness
i'm gonna put that in my butthole
never happened straight as [ __ ]
[Music]
that's great dude my friends are like
dude we're so lucky we're not gay being
gay
sucks i was like yeah they have such
good fashion but yeah it sucks
like yeah baby sucks can you imagine if
most of the gender that you were
attracted to
wasn't attracted to your back and i was
like whoa
can't even imagine
[Music]
where is cry constantly the gays
again possibly uh but i love
the gays uh on the way over here i saw a
member of the transgender community i
saw a bicyclist who identified as an
automobile
you use your turn signal kia
i've got a rule in the road
i i hate the carpool lane i feel like
the car pulling is like society saying
hey you know how you're lonely
yeah do it for longer you loser
watch people with friends whizzing by
you
you're going so fast how can i make
friends
and they're going so fast so
yeah i mean i love i love dating around
um
it's pretty cool a lot of ladies like to
call me a premature ejaculator
which uh first of all premature to who
i came at the perfect time when i felt
amazing
it takes maturity to know how to please
yourself
busting nuts
so yeah i mean it's hard to date as an
asian man because everyone thinks asian
women
are beautiful but not everyone thinks
asian men are beautiful
but how do you think asian women are
created
[Music]
mean [ __ ] of a crucial process
in the sexy creation method
okay please stop trying to skip me
i hate uh asian women they act like
they're so much better than asian men
but uh asian women we look exactly the
same
[Applause]
i could throw on a wig and be a seven
relax
why are you bragging that you can [ __ ]
white dudes
everyone can [ __ ] white dudes
[Applause]
that's not something to brag about
i could [ __ ] a white dude tonight
um i uh i love uh america
uh i don't understand all the sayings in
english american
because uh in prison they say don't drop
the soap
it should be don't pick up the soap
it's bending over where they really get
you you know
even if you don't drop the soap you're
still to get raped you're just going to
have really clean hands while it happens
why isn't this working who are these
rapists like man i want to get that kid
but he never drops the soap
does he have a butthole
i don't know the go-getter they don't
take no for an answer in those rapists
but uh i love do you think you think
cops have a hand fetish
that's when i was like hey let me see
your hands
nice make them touch
put them by your butt
um i am i'm not a racist i'm an asian
impossible i'm a minority how could i be
um i don't even see race
i only smell it
smells a little polish um i was on a
plane with a dude who was reading a book
in
arabic which kind of freaked me out but
then i saw him fold a corner of the page
and put the book away and i was like oh
thank god he's got future plans
it's not going to blow us up he's got a
narrative to finish
um i love the black panther movie
uh i thought that was a great movie
because of being black children a hero
they could finally look up to
and not just someone like maya angelou
or
harriet tubman or martin vicki jr or
cindy poitier or will smith or
jackie robinson lebron james michael
jordan
uh now there's a fake person dressed
like a cat
[Music]
what are they gonna come out with a
yellow panda huh
jack black does not count
he's a cartoon he's not asian um i uh
i think it's funny that tanner is a
white person's name you know
tanner that went
should be like hey this is my mexican
friend tanner
that's my black friend tanist
all right that was my time thank you
guys very much
[Applause]